prime minister has put himself at odds
with teaching unions by saying that
parents should send their children
back to school on monday in areas where
they're open
schools are safe very very important to
stress that the the the threat to
the risk to to kids to young people is
really very very very small
boris johnson says schools are safe but
the government scientists say they
should be shut to tackle the virus his
government is already responsible for
the unnecessary deaths of tens of
thousands of people
it can't be trusted teachers can i back
the national education union
i stand in solidarity with teachers and
head teachers who are taking the fight
to this government
forcing them to listen to sage's advice
to close
schools schools are not safe they must
close
listen to sage more blatant
misrepresentation by boris johnson
he appears on mars this morning
insisting the schools are safe
but forgets to mention that his own
scientist told him that he can't get on
top of kvit19
without closing schools the question of
whether children should go back to
school after the christmas holidays has
been heatedly debated the government's
facing pressure from teachers
he wants schools to remain closed in
england for two more weeks
currently most primary schools are
expected to open in england excluding
ones in london
the return of secondary schools is
expected later this month
john hall a teacher and member of a
teaching trade union shared with us his
frustration
i find it reasonable that they keep the
schools in the capital closed
yes but also what they should what they
should look to do
is because london schools are in tier
four
i work in newcastle upon tyne which is
in the northeast of england
who are in tier four there are lots of
areas of england which are in tier four
and so if london schools are going to be
kept
closed from january the 4th then we
expect all schools in tier 4
to remain closed at the moment it's it's
not up to the government
as to whether schools will will um
reopen
it is up to each and every employer the
government is not the employer of
teachers in england
the nas uwt teachers union has written
to
each employer asking them to
carry out a new risk assessment to
ensure that these schools
are safe and that is why january the 4th
is not a reasonable date for
schools to reopen um we think
it will take at least a week to two
weeks before
this consultation with staff can take
place and that schools
are made safe the outcry
comes as the uk sees a major spike in
daily coronavirus infections
following christmas nearly 55 000 new
cases were reported on sunday
the total number of cases has surpassed
2.6 million
with more than 75 000 deaths john hall
again accuses the government of
mishandling the pandemic
the government have not consulted
with the teachers and their union
representatives
the governments have made mistakes time
and time again
the government have not listened to the
sage
uh committee which advises them
regarding the virus
so on on a scale of not to 10 with 10
being excellent
i suppose i will give the government
maybe one and that's just being there
nobody knows what is happening from one
day to the next
the teaching profession and certainly
the naswt
teachers union has no confidence
at all in the government in the way that
they are handling
this pandemic and certainly and how they
are handling
the education of students in this
country
you